der russische Präsident hat die
Teilmobilmachung angeordnet und er hat
noch einmal davor gewarnt er könne
Atomwaffen einsetzen wörtlich sagte er
das ist kein Bluff begrüße sie hat sich
im Studio Professor Ulrich Schmidt Herr
Schmidt wir haben eine teilmobil-machung
haben wir damit auch einen Wendepunkt
wir haben jetzt neue Proteste in
Russland Unruhe in Russland wenn auch in
kleinen Maßstab ist da ein Wendepunkt im
Augenblick erreicht Putin steht mit dem
Rücken zur Wand und das ist
gewissermaßen seine whatever it takes
Mitteilung anders Ausland er ist gewillt
gewissermaßen jetzt auch den Krieg
mitten in die Gesellschaft
hineinzutragen und er hat damit
klargemacht dass er nicht zurückweichen
will
ich mit sie sind an der Universität St
Gallen zuständig als Professor für
Literatur und Gesellschaft Russlands
wir fragen uns ja seit dem 24 Februar
wie reagiert die russische Bevölkerung
was ist da der Grund dafür dass wir so
wenig Rebellion erleben das ist
eigentlich in Russland relativ ruhig
bleibt oder ist das ein falscher
Eindruck es gab ja gleich nach dem 24
Februar einige Proteste und zwar in
vielen Städten in Russland und es gibt
eine
zivilgesellschaftliche Organisation die
diese Proteste dokumentiert und es ist
sehr schön wenn man anschaut auf der
Zeitachse wie diese Proteste verteilt
sind da sieht man dass wir bisher 16.000
Fälle gehabt haben von solchen Protesten
und 15.000 von diesen 16.000 fanden im
ersten Monat statt und das Zeug
natürlich nicht davon dass die
Proteststimmung jetzt einfach
verschwunden ist
sondern dass die massive Repression im
Start funktioniert seit Kriegsbeginn ist
denn Russen und Russinnen bewusst was da
stattfindet ist das im
gesellschaftlichen Bewusstsein
angekommen ja das ist angekommen es gibt
ja immer wieder diese Zahl die zitiert
wird das 80 Prozent der Russen diese
spezial-operation unterstützen das muss
man mit einem Körnchen Salz nehmen denn
das ist eigentlich nur das was die
Russen bereit sind öffentlich zu sagen
es gibt in der russischen Gesellschaft
natürlich keinen breiten Konsens wie das
damals 2014 bei der Annexion der Krim
war dass das jetzt die Zukunft Russlands
bedeutet dieser Krieg wird als
notwendiges Übel akzeptiert und wir
werden jetzt sehen was in Zukunft
passieren wird
mit der russischen Gesellschaft wenn
nicht nur die mehreren 10.000 Toten dann
auch wirklich im Bewusstsein der Leute
ankommen sondern ist das inzwischen ist
es so dass man weiß da ist ein Sohn
umgekommen und man erfährt auch das ist
in der Ukraine gewesen unter den und den
Umständen ist das bewusst das wird
natürlich weitgehend unter dem Deckel
gehalten Putin hat ja gleich zu Beginn
des Krieges auch massive Zahlungen
versprochen für Angehörige von Opfern
aber offiziell
gesteht das
Verteidigungsministerium ja erst etwas
6000 Opfer ein das ist ein Bruchteil
dessen wovon wir eigentlich ausgehen
müssen
wir haben ungefähr 300.000 Reservisten
um die es jetzt geht bei dieser time
mobil machen das bedeutet aber auch
300.000 die eine Familie im Zweifel
haben die Eltern haben die Großeltern
haben die vielleicht Kinder haben
bedeutet das nicht auch dass dieser
Krieg sehr viel stärker noch in die
Familien in das Bewusstsein der
Gesellschaft kommt so ist es und ich
glaube dass die Militärbehörden sehr
genau wissen dass das Protestpotenzial
sehr hoch ist ich habe jetzt erste
Informationen von Bekannten aus Russland
wo
aus dem Umfeld Leute diesen
Stellungsbefehl bekommen haben und
offensichtlich wird da nicht sehr streng
durchgesetzt also wenn man drauf
verweist dass man junge Kinder hat dann
wird man nicht direkt eingezogen diese
300.000 sind ja eigentlich ja auch nur
ein Bruchteil der verfügbaren Menge von
Reservisten in Russland
wir haben ja immer wieder die Frage uns
gestellt
wie ist diese
Aktion von Putin der ja die Demokratie
auch insgesamt runtergefahren hat also
demokratischen Bemühungen in Russland
wie ist dieses Bewusstsein bei den
Menschen angekommen fühlen die sich in
einem Russland was nicht mehr
demokratisch ist
noch wohl gibt es da Reaktionen drauf
merkt man das im Alltag oder kommt
dieser alte Spruch zu Tage wieder naja
in Russland kann man viel ertragen man
muss differenzieren dass Elektrorad von
Putin befindet sich hauptsächlich in den
ländlichen Gebieten dort wird
hauptsächlich auch nur Staatsfernsehen
geschaut und spätestens eben seit den
großen Protesten des Winters
2011/2012 ist ja diese Propaganda
Maschinerie sehr sehr gut geölt worden
ich glaube dort gibt es ja keine große
Proteststimmung anders sieht es aus in
den zwei Hauptstädten petersburg und
Moskau und in den übrigen 12
millionenstätten in Russland gibt es
eine sehr gut informierte kritische
Intelligenz ja wie kommen die an
Informationen es ist ja so dass Facebook
und Twitter gesperrt sind in Russland
aber in jeder der sich auch nur
einigermaßen auskennt hat ein VPN und
youtube ist nach wie vor nicht gesperrt
und die gesperrten Sender wie zum
Beispiel der russische Dienst von BBC
Deutsche Welle oder Radio free Europe
die produzieren ihre Bilder auf
Youtube und dann gibt es ein
Oppositionellen Kanal der heißt Medusa
und der sagt vor jeder Meldung explizit
druckt das was er hier seht aus und geht
es euren Großmüttern und euren
Großvätern damit die auch zu kritischer
und unabhängiger Informationen kommen
wir erleben ja in allen Ländern
ähnlicher Strukturen
[Musik]
dass die medieninstrumentalisiert werden
relativ schnell und sehr gezielt das was
dort in Russland passiert ist lange
lange vorbereitet worden ja das ist so
und zwar hat das relativ bald nach
Putins Amtsantritt im Jahr 2000 begonnen
sehnen sich an den Untergang des
atom-u-boots Kursk das war das erste PR
Desaster von Putin als er gesagt hat in
einem Interview als er gefragt wird was
ist eigentlich passiert und dann hat er
gesagt das Boot ist gesunken und das war
natürlich ein Schlag ins Gesicht für die
Angehörigen und damals hat Putin sehr
sehr schnell alle Fernsehsender auf
Linie gebracht das hat ihm übrigens
sogar auch eine Verurteilung des
Menschenrechtsgerichtshofs in Straßburg
eingebracht weil er den Sender n-tv
wirklich mit Mafia Methoden unter seine
Kontrolle gebracht hat
wir haben
Gegenstimmen
zunehmend Gegenstimmen von Prominenten
nicht von denjenigen die sich ohnehin
immer gegen
Putin und seine Region gestellt haben
sondern etwa zum Beispiel von der so
sagt man Pop-Ikone aller pugatschowa die
sehr bekannt ist die sehr beliebt ist
können die sich jetzt sozusagen aus der
Reserve Wagen und offen so etwas machen
und was passiert da auf Dauer aller
pukatova ist tatsächlich eine Größe im
russischen Showbusiness allerdings ist
sie mit ihrem Mann bereits kurz nach dem
Krieg nach Israel ausgereist das heißt
also sie ist einerseits nicht so
exponiert auf der anderen Seite ist
natürlich damit auch ihre Reichweite
beschränkt bleibt zwar zahlreiche
Follower auf den sozialen Medien aber
ich denke auch das ist eigentlich ein
wichtiges Signal an die russische
Öffentlichkeit
pugatschowa hat zum Beispiel im Dezember
2014 also nach der Annexion der Krim
noch einen Preis aus den Händen von
Präsident Putin entgegengenommen
das heißt aber auch da gibt es eine
gewisse Erosion die wir jetzt
feststellen eben auch bei Dingen die in
der Öffentlichkeit stattfinden die nicht
nur hinter den Kulissen stattfinden denn
sie persönlich Kontakte die Sie überall
in die osteuropäischen Länder haben und
natürlich auch nach Russland in die
Ukraine
anrufen mit denen sprechen wie reagieren
die was bekommen sie von denen erzählt
also Kollegen aus der Universität in
Russland die sind natürlich schockiert
zum Teil bin ich auch erstaunt wie offen
sie sich zum Beispiel auf Facebook
äußern natürlich haben sie diese
Äußerung auf ihre Freunde beschränkt
aber trotzdem es gibt viele sehr sehr
mutige Stimmen in Russland aber das gilt
natürlich nicht für die breite
Öffentlichkeit erhöht die breite
Öffentlichkeit ist dieser Krieg bisher
etwas gewesen was weit entfernt
stattfindet Putin hat ja auch gesagt das
sind Spezialisten die sich sehr
professionell kümmern um diese
militärische Spezialaktion ist weit weg
und wir können wir können ihn Vertrauen
und eigentlich könnt ihr jetzt euer
Leben weiterführen und Putin ist der
komplett auch überrascht gewesen vom
Ausmaß der Sanktionen aber es gab einen
Bericht einer
Radiojournalistin die hat Leute im Kreml
befragt eben wie sie denn stehen jetzt
zu diesem kriegsentscheid und direkt
nach dem 24 Februar hat sie schockierte
Reaktionen gekriegt die Leute haben
gesagt wir können das nicht mittragen
sie hat dieselben Leute im Mai noch
einmal befragt und dann waren die
Antworten ganz anders
sagt so eine Art konsolidierungseffekt
gegeben und dieselben Leute die sich im
Februar schockiert gezeigt haben haben
im Mai gesagt eben die Sanktionen des
Westen sind komplett unverhältnismäßig
und wenn der Westen nichts von uns
wissen will dann wollen wir auch nichts
mehr vom Westen wissen ist das eine
politische Äußerung gewesen oder eine
wirklich persönliche ich denke das war
eine persönliche Äußerung denn im Moment
ist natürlich auch der Aktionsradius der
Leute die sich in und um den Kreml herum
bewegen sehr beengt sie haben keine
auswärtsoptionen mehr und das ist
natürlich auch so ein bisschen eine
prekäre
stabilitätsgarantie für Putin sprechen
wir mal über
dieses Motiv bei Putin es gibt Philosoph
Philosophen die
genannt werden es gibt Literatur die
genannt wird aber letztendlich läuft es
darauf hinaus dass das was dort
stattfindet durch Putin eine
Rechtfertigung nur in der Historie
findet aber nicht im Völkerrecht also er
setzt sich eigentlich über das
Völkerrecht komplett hinweg und sagt wir
haben einen historischen Anspruch
also was man sicher sagen kann ist das
Ideologie ein treibender Faktor gewesen
ist für die Kriegsentscheidung
putin ist nicht jemand der seinen
Publikum vermittelt dass er das
Völkerrecht bricht im Gegenteil er hat
schon 2014 immer
pseudolegalistische Begründungen
vorgebracht für die Annexion der Krim
und dasselbe war in seiner inoffiziellen
Kriegserklärung vom 24 Februar der Fall
er hat dort explizit gesagt ich ordne im
Einklang mit Artikel 51 der Charter der
Vereinten Nationen dieser
spezialoperation an nun wissen wir
natürlich nicht aus dem Stegreif was
Artikel 51 ist Artikel 51 ist das
Selbstverteidigungsrecht eines Staates
wenn er angegriffen wird und auf das hat
sich Putin am 24 Februar absurder diese
berufen aber das zeigt sehr deutlich
nicht also dass auch bei der Anwendung
des Völkerrechts genau dasselbe gilt wie
in der Anwendung des Rechts in Russland
selber das sondern nämlich selektiv
irgendetwas herauspickt und das dann zu
seinen eigenen Gunsten einsetzt und eben
was völlig vergessen geht sind natürlich
die vordersten Artikel nämlich eins und
zwei der UNO harter in der sogar die
Androhung und dann natürlich auch die
Anwendung von Gewalt untersagt wird
darüber schweigt Putty das ist aber
eigentlich genauso der Fall wie bei der
Einschätzung der Ukraine er sagt ja das
ist eine eigene Sprache die dort
gesprochen wird und da gibt es auch
kulturelle Traditionen aber sie gehören
eigentlich zu diesem ganz großen
russischen Reich zur Nation das ist eine
Differenzierung die man nicht
nachvollziehen kann
ja ich denke Putin habt natürlich in den
letzten Jahren immer wieder versucht
auch als Historiker aufzutreten ich
glaube in viele Beobachter sagen es geht
ihm nur noch um seinen macht Erhalt habe
das interessiert ihn nicht mehr nach
fast einem Vierteljahrhundert an der
Macht er möchte jetzt seinen Platz in
den Geschichtsbüchern sichern und ist
diese Idee vom Zaren die wirklich
dahinter steckt ja also Putin geht ja
sehr erklektisch vor in seiner
Geschichtsbetrachtung er nimmt alles aus
der russischen Geschichte was ihn
irgendwie nützt und eines der zentralen
Credos ist
die Rede von der tausendjährigen
Staatlichkeit
Russlands er führt das auf die
sogenannte Kia Varus zurück das erste
ostslawische Staatsgebilde man hat das
auch gesehen
[Musik]
2016 wurde direkt vor dem Kreml eine
große Statue eingeweiht für den Kira
Fürsten Vladimir dem 10 jahrhundert
gelebt hat und Putin
leitet eigentlich eben die Existenz der
heutigen Staatlichkeit Russlands von der
Kia Varus ab und dieses Denkmal ist
einigermaßen absurd weil der Kia war
Fürst Vladimir nie in Moskau war nie in
Moskau sein konnte einfach weil es
Moskau am 10 jahrhundert noch nicht gab
sie kennen sich in der russischen
Literatur sehr gut aus wir haben eben
über die Medien gesprochen auch da haben
sie intensiv geforscht in den letzten
Jahren
kann man die Einstellung in Russland ja
zumindest bei den nicht-oppositionellen
durchaus verbreitet ist von diesem
Riesenreich von dieser besonderen Nation
dieser Nation die auch über den anderen
Nationen steht kann man die irgendwie
nachvollziehen wie die entstanden ist
also es gibt natürlich auch unter
russischen
Oppositionellen immer wieder Aussagen
über die Ukraine nehmen Sie zum Beispiel
ein entschiedenen Gegner der Bolschewiki
wie zum Beispiel piotruwe der ist nach
der Oktoberrevolution geflohen war
eigentlich ein Vertreter von liberalen
Gedankengut aber auch für ihn war klar
dass die Ukraine Teil Russland sein muss
dasselbe gilt auch für entschiedene
Oppositionelle wie Alexander social need
sind oder den
Literaturnobelpreisträger Josef brotzki
die haben beide auch offen gesagt die
Ukraine kann kein eigener Staat sein und
gehört zu Russland
wie stark ist das denn der russischen
Bevölkerung verwurzelt ich würde sagen
in der großrussischen Bevölkerung ist
das relativ präsent und vielleicht kann
man hier auch daran erinnern dass in der
ukrainischen Geistes Geschichte selber
im 19 Jahrhundert es eine Reihe von
Intellektuellen gab die sich als
Föderalisten bezeichnet haben zum
Beispiel Michaela gomanow das einer der
wichtigsten
Protagonisten des ukrainischen
nationalprojekt sind 19 Jahrhundert hat
kein eigenen ukrainischen Staat
gefordert sondern gesagt eben es müsse
eine Föderation aus Ukraine und Russland
geben
die haben ja Umfragen gemacht in den
letzten Jahren und die Umfragen deuten
darauf hin dass diese Rückmeldung wir
gehören eigentlich zu Russland in der
Ukraine überhaupt nicht verbreitet ist
um völlig unverständlich man muss mal
ganz einfach sagen hätte Putin ihre
Umfragen gelesen hätte er sich
wahrscheinlich doch noch mal überlegt
in die Ukraine einzumarschieren denn die
Bevölkerung ist ja gar nicht so Russland
freundlich was haben sie da festgestellt
wir haben einen Forschungsprojekt zum
Regionalismus in der Ukraine
durchgeführt und wir wollten vor allem
das Vorurteil überprüfen dass die
Russland dass die Ukraine in zwei
Hälften gespalten ist nämlich in ein
provestel proeuropäischen Westen und in
ein russischen Osten
und was wir festgestellt haben ist
folgendes 2013 und 2015 haben wir zwei
Umfragen gemacht also direkt vor der
Krim Annektion und direkt nach der Krim
Annexion und wir haben festgestellt dass
es auch im Osten eine starke Zustimmung
zum ukrainischen Staat gibt auch wenn
man das nicht an der eigenen Sprache
festmacht und bereits die Annexion der
Creme hat gezeigt dass die Aggression
Russlands die Zustimmung zum
ukrainischen nationalprojekt auch im
Osten verstärkt hat und letztlich glaube
ich kann man die ukrainische
Nationsbildung mit der italienischen
vergleichen die italienische
Nationsbildung ging ja auch
vom Pimmel Mond aus und hat sich dann
über die Halbinsel über den Stiefel
weiter nach Süden ausgebreitet und
dasselbe ist der Fall in der Ukraine das
nationalprojekt wurde vorbereitet in
Galizien in West in der Westukraine und
hat sich seither nach Osten verbreitet
und man kann durchaus sagen es ist jetzt
an der kontaktlinie angekommen
wenn sie mit
Russen mit Ukrainern besprochen haben in
den letzten Jahren
wenn Sie die Literatur studiert haben
wenn sie gesehen haben wie Putin
insgesamt agiert der den Staat immer
stärker
sozusagen zentralisiert hat auf seine
Person
haben sie trotzdem
überrascht reagiert auf den 24 februar
oder hatten Sie das Gefühl das ist
eigentlich die logische Konsequenz nein
ich war komplett überrascht ich hatte
nicht gedacht dass Putin angreifen würde
aus dem einfachen Grund weil dieses
Desaster dass wir jetzt haben eigentlich
komplett vorhersehbar war es war
vorhersehbar das Russland sich in eine
internationale Isolation begeben würde
es war vorhersehbar dass der Widerstand
in der Ukraine massiv ausfallen würde
auch aufgrund ihrer Umfragen ja und
offensichtlich eben ist Putin und sein
Ängste Führungszeugnis aber davon
ausgegangen eben dass dieses historische
Russland so stark ist dass man das jetzt
herbeiführen kann haben sie haben Sie so
eine Rückmeldung auch in den letzten
vielleicht auch im letzten Jahr bekommen
von ihren russischen Kontakten wir haben
Sie darüber gesprochen es ist sicher
immer weiter zugespitzt ja es ist so und
eben viele meiner russischen Bekannten
und Kollegen
haben sich einerseits dann empört
gezeigt es gibt einige die ihre Stellen
gekündigt hat es gibt auch solche die
jetzt im Ausland sind und eben von
diesen notstipenden die ja von vielen
Ländern bereitgestellt wurden
profitieren aber es gibt natürlich auch
viele die sich arrangieren mit der
Situation ich habe zum Beispiel kürzlich
einen Kollegen aus einem akademischen
Institut in Moskau getroffen der ist
nach Deutschland geflohen direkt nach
Kriegsausbruch und hat sich sehr
kritisch über seine eigenen Söhne
geäußert die in Moskau geblieben sind
die haben dort Jobs die haben Familie
die haben gesagt wir überwintern dort
und der Vater hat gesagt das ist
eigentlich inakzeptabel und so sieht man
wieder Riss durch die Familien geht
wir haben ja eine sehr merkwürdige
oligarchentruppe um Putin herum
merkwürdig deswegen weil man ja auch
immer vom Westen her dachte man kann die
instrumentalisieren also man kann den
Privilegien wegnehmen sie dürfen nicht
mehr den Westen reisen ihnen werden im
Zweifelsfall auch große Summen die
Yachten waren ein Symbol im Grunde dafür
weggenommen da gibt es den Alisha
osmanov der am Tegernsee residierte und
angeblich eine Steuerhinterziehung von
555 Millionen Euro durchgeführt hat die
muss man ja auch mal hochrechnen auf das
Gesamteinkommen das hat aber nicht
funktioniert warum eigentlich wir haben
ja glaube ich am Anfang so gedacht ne
die rebellieren dann gegen Putin
das ist der große Unterschied bei den
Oligarchen einerseits in Russland und
andererseits in der Ukraine putin hatte
schon sehr sehr früh zu Beginn der
2000er Jahre mit der Disziplinierung der
Oligarchen begonnen und hat das
erfolgreich durchgeführt Stichwort
hottekowski nicht der sich nicht beugen
wollte und dann zehn Jahre hinter
Gittern verschwand in der Ukraine gibt
es auch Oligarchen die sind aber relativ
mächtig und das hat dann paradoxerweise
auch zu einer Vielfalt in der
Medienlandschaft geführt weil jeder
Oligarch in der Ukraine einen eigenen
Fernsehkanal hatte und die haben sich
natürlich auf den Fernsehkanälen
gegenseitig bekämpft während man in
Russland eigentlich nur das
gleichgestaltete Staatsfernsehen hatte
kommt von denen noch was oder muss man
im Grunde sagen der
versucht die Oligarchen zu
instrumentalisieren ist schief gelaufen
die Oligarchen haben ja oder zwei
Oligarchen haben ein schüchtern Versuch
unternommen das haben ihn wir sollten
diesen Krieg beenden natürlich haben die
Oligarchen in dieser Situation überhaupt
keinen Einfluss mehr auf den Kreml
man muss sich natürlich fragen wer hat
jetzt überhaupt noch einen Einfluss auf
den Kreml und auf Putin persönlich es
ist ja so dass Putin sich auch in sein
geschichtsphilosophischen Einlassung
immer wieder sehr sehr abschätzig über
die letzten startslenker des Zarenreichs
und der Sowjetunion geäußert hat das
sind für ihn Schwächlinge die es
zugelassen haben eben das ein starker
Start in nicht mehr die Größe hat die im
Zug kommt und ich glaube das ist das was
ihn im Moment lenkt
was ihn lenkt aber was auch seine große
Gefahr ist in einem Buch was man
wirklich sehr empfehlen kann aus Europa
zwischen Mauerfall und Ukraine Krieg
werden diese historischen Hintergründe
aufgezeigt von Ihnen und den anderen die
dort Autoren sind und da kommt auch
dieses Problem für ihn zum Tragen dass
er komplett isoliert ist wie lange kann
man eine solche Isolation
durchhalten ohne das tatsächlich
irgendjemand
neben ihm steht und ihn wegräumt
es gibt ja die Vermutung dass die
Teilmobilmachung nicht Putins eigene
Initiative ist sondern dass der Druck
der Falken und der Kriegspartei im Kreml
so groß geworden ist das Putin ein
Zugeständnis machen muss derjenigen die
es anheizen genau derjenigen die sagen
eben hätten wir schon längst in einen
Krieg überführen müssen und ich denke
aber dass Putin möglicherweise jetzt
dann auch selber sieht dass er nicht
mehr an der Spezi dieses Staates stehen
kann einfach weil er einerseits auf dem
internationalen Parkett zu einer
toxischen Figur gekommen ist und
zweitens weil er sich auch in politisch
nur durch massive Repression an der
Macht halten kann es gab im Sommer
eine außerordentliche Sitzung des
Parlaments und dort wurde ein
neuer stellvertretender
Ministerpräsident ernannt Denise
mantorow
ein Technokrat ich könnte mir vorstellen
dass es so etwas wie ein
gorbatschow-szenario jetzt auch für die
Putin Zeit geben könnte das Putin aber
das ist das positivste Szenario das ist
ein optimistisches Szenario das Putin
2024 nicht mehr kandidieren wird für die
Präsidentschaft und dass man ein loyalen
Technokraten auf den Schild heben wird
wie zum Beispiel eben Denise mantorow
der zuständig ist für die Stabilisierung
der russischen Wirtschaft und den
sogenannten Import Ersatz das ist aber
auch eine indirekte Folge des Resümee
ist dieser Regierungszeit von Putin denn
wir müssen ja feststellen jetzt im Krieg
hat er sich komplett isoliert sie haben
gerade von der toxischen Situation für
ihn geschworen auch von der Text
toxischen Gestalt aber letztendlich muss
man ja auch feststellen russland steht
auf Platz 11 der
Wirtschaftsmächte das ist ein
desaströses Ergebnis und bis heute hat
Putin ist nicht geschafft dieses Land
wirklich zu modernisieren und zu einem
Land zu machen was außer den Rohstoffen
auch wirklich Technologie entwickelt ja
und das ist ein großes Problem Putin hat
sich in den ersten zehn Jahren seiner
Amtszeit darauf verlassen dass Gas und
Öl immer neue Dollars in die Staatskasse
spielen das hat relativ lange relativ
gut funktioniert was aber nicht
funktioniert hat ist in
Rahmenbedingungen zu schaffen für eine
blühende Wirtschaft und das ist
natürlich jetzt komplett zerstört worden
es gibt überhaupt keine Rechtssicherheit
mehr auf absehbare Zeit wird es keine
Ausland Investitionen geben in Russland
und das ist natürlich desaströs für die
russische Wirtschaft wir haben auch
gesehen
dass die die russische staatsbilanz
jetzt ins Negative gerutscht ist und
eigentlich steht Putin wirtschaftlich
das Wasser am Hals
in dem Buch ist ein schöner Satz die
corona-pandemie hat das Missverhältnis
zwischen Anspruch und Realität
autoritärer Regierungsführung gezeigt
das betrifft ja nicht nur Russland
sondern auch andere Regierungen in der
Welt die autoritär geführt werden und
der schöne Schlusssatz ist die
Bevölkerung Russlands ist für die
Demokratie noch nicht verloren
das ist so also Russland ist eine alte
europäische Kulturnation und ich glaube
dass das was wir jetzt sehen so eine Art
nordkurius Nordkorea Szenario das lässt
sich mit der russischen Bevölkerung
nicht lange durchhalten es wird zu
Protesten kommen aber im man kann
natürlich nicht die Demokratie einfach
von heute auf morgen einführen es gibt
ganz ganz wichtige Voraussetzungen und
die zwei wichtigsten sind meiner Meinung
nach ein funktionierendes Parteiensystem
haben wir nicht wir haben nur
pseudo-parteien in Russland und ein
funktionierendes Mediensystem haben wir
auch nicht in Russland wir haben nur
staatliche oder staatsname Medien
das heißt aber das Resümee von Ihnen
persönlich ist ein Resümee was durchaus
einen gewissen Optimismus noch zulässt
ja ich würde sagen Russland wird sich
nicht so schnell befreien können aus in
diesem nationalistisch patriotischen und
Drive indem sie sich befinden einfach
weil die elitenauswahl in den letzten 20
Jahren genau auf diesem Prinzip
funktioniert hat Russland ist keine
Meritokratie sondern Loyalität hat alles
andere übertrumpft und aus dieser
Sackgasse herauszukommen wird extrem
schwierig zu sein es gibt sehr
engagierte und
moralisch
makelloser Leute wie zum Beispiel
loboxobel eine
Politikerin aus Moskau die sich jetzt
auch im Ausland befindet die
zurückkommen könnten aber im Moment ist
die Situation so dieser strös dass das
kein Szenario für die nächste Zukunft
ist
Professor mit ganz herzlichen Dank dass
Sie bei mir waren danke
[Musik]